ik が寂しかったので
店を置いてみたよ
だあああああああ
e doctor 始めた皆さん pastor 部存じでしょうかスカ芸
てればねぇねぇぜ
ああああああ
ぐらいしかしておりませんが after 食べる人いると思うんですよでパンダって
作る前って実は凄い硬くてですねこういう細いもうみたいになっているわけですよこれ
を茹でて二役にして食べたらパスタなんですけども課題増大のパスタにですね実は科学
的な秘密がありましてそれを考えたらまずご紹介しようと思いますそれでパパ設定だ
けどこれどうでもスパゲッティですねめっちゃ
スパゲッティすぱげっていいか至ったというわけで子スパゲティなんですけどもあり
科学者によりますとスパゲッティ
必ず3つ以上に折れるという伝承があるらしいです必ずってすごいですねつまりですよ
こうやってパスたら日本ありますよとこれで居ると絶対さんのようになったっていう
ことがあるんですよ
[音楽]
ほらほらほら飛びました俺たちが真ん中で折れて3本になっちゃったんですねこれこれ
稽古すごくないったらなんか日本に一度なんですよ絶対またみてねと真ん中の曲なる
からほら
ん
[音楽]
っていう要因ですねスパゲッティ切るとき観覧ず3つになっちゃっていう説があったん
ですけどもうなんと2018年
めっちゃ祭神ですね八ツ口に乾燥したスパゲッティを両手で持って厚型に曲げて嘔吐
するとまず間違いなく3つ以上に折れてしまうという不思議な現象が存在するんですか
誰でしょうがどれだけ頑張っても乗り越えられなかったスパゲッティおりのミステリー
をついに取り声スパゲッティをきれいに2つに
あることに成功した学者がいたらしいでございます須郷なんか気子スパゲッティのこの
をれるのって結構歴史が深いらしいですねピッティが折れた時に生じるタワー3が
伝わる時の波が合成されて強くなりてあなた直れ目が作られてしまって3本になっ
ちゃうみたいなそれが逆にですね2つに折る方法はないのかという謎に取り組んだ科学
者がいたらしいです
コーネル大学の台が
グイン生であるロナルドハイザー州とマサチューセッツ工科大学の大学院生じゃある
ビッシュあるパネル白のチームらしいです
誰ないろいろその開発は研究とか繰り返した結果ですねスパゲッティを一定が角度に
ねじっておいた状態で曲げていくと
2つに折れるという結論に至ったらしいですね自然の3本以上の折れちゃっていうのが
判明されてから13年の時
を得てようやく日本にはれる方法が見つかったらしいです強気で皆さんにこの世紀の大
発見を今私が教えましょうか湧いてるパパの手を両手で居る時に2つに折れる方法は
スパゲッティを270度ディ自立しつつ秒速3mm で折り曲げていくことで感的に
半分にを練るらしいです
まじか曲細いですね常にこれ二つに折れるというのを発見されたの結構記事になってる
の2018年なので多分2018年にぱげってぃが2つに割る方法が見つかったんじゃ
ないかなと思われますってことは私もですよドクターはじめも頑張れば270所ネジ力
ヴァイスとで予測サービスメートルで負ける
マップ時が折れるんじゃねーかということでどれくらいぜひちょっとちょっとあの
できればでやってみます何度が奇跡の二つ折りスパゲッティ成功させていきたいと
おもいます今バネに吹かの絶対不利と言われていたのと今から私やりますから世紀の
瞬間をご覧ください
4いきますね
やっぱ無理なん
[音楽]
ああ
ああやっぱり丁寧なアーチなどで可愛いてみてどうしてもこう
弾丸でお方から地下た力入れていくと落ちちゃうんじゃねこっこの間がポロってでは
早速270度ねじりを p で両側3mm で曲げていこうと思いますまあ制御だ百均
に言うとこれで綺麗にをれるはずなので
270度回転でのは難しい
こんなもんだと思いますもう拗ねるちょっと曲がってますねこれに秒速3mm
ゆーくり言ってきたん
ええええええ
me
あっはぁ
ちょっと今何回かやってみたんですけども別にあの子練りとか予測3mm とかなくて
も普通にできますはさ
なんだこれ面がいいのかなぁそれが乾燥してないからか
いやでも感想をどう1してるよね新しい使っても誰も普通に生きると思うよ
ホラー免震化したか名神か探しんですけど多分全然そんなねじりとかなくても普通に
アーサーたまに版だがポロってなりますけど基本的に全然イケますよこれあだめだ